when you catch it you're strong shot
pulling it you're great your drivve is
great keep that aggressiveness the whole
time be in attack mod attack that Rim
get around release and get here give
yourself a little room so that if he
lock in lobs you can go with him cuz
you're quicker than he is but don't just
sit here and go behind him make that
pass time make him catch it out there
you got to be you got to be disciplined
a little bit just k your hands keep your
hands out you can do it you can do this
yeah don't worry about it come on
you got to be you got to be active if
you don't shoot it you got to catch it
drive it don't wait for a pick and roll
it's a bad formula to be coming this way
when Giannis is going this way fast you
got to drop same thing with lilling make
them shoot a floater but you got to be
Dro and be back on that thing at that
point or they're going to go right by
you they negate all your height and your
length